good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the European Parliament here in
Strasbourg my name is Maria and the
single Market has just turned 30 since
its Creation in 1993 the single Market
has helped to make everyday life easier
for people and businesses fueling with
jobs and growth across the EU to discuss
what lies ahead for one of the greatest
achievements of the European Union I am
joined today by Miss Anna cavatsini the
chair of parliament's committee on
internal market and consumer protection
welcome means cavazini hello thank you
for your time today so before we get
underway with the interview I'd like our
audience who our life on Facebook
LinkedIn and YouTube to send us your to
send us your questions and comments and
I'll try to put as many as possible to
my guest in the next half an hour or so
mistake let's start
um what is the current state of the
European single Market
yeah here in Strasbourg we just
celebrated the 30 years of the single
market and when you listen to the debate
and plenary you saw really every member
of the European Parliament talked about
the big achievements you know like in
the last 30 years Europe grew together
and with his Four Freedoms like persons
can move freely Capital products and so
on it is really
um we can say European integration was
achieved was put forward and I think
this is really one of the biggest
achievement of the internal market and
what are the the main benefits of the
single market and how has it transformed
the European Union
yeah um instead of
um yeah 50 000 different National norms
and standards instead of
big customs declarations
um European companies can just sell on
the products all over Europe and we as
consumers we profit from more choice but
also from lower prices next to the fact
that of course we also can move freely
work study live everywhere in the
European Union and I think this was of
course the whole idea of founding the
single Market to leverage this economic
Prosperity but I would say there's much
more than the economic side to the
single Market especially in the last
years we managed to also really increase
with our EU legislation that we're doing
in this Parliament
the product standards for example to
make sure all the products are safe all
the products really have very high
standards in the European Union or to
abolish roaming so that consumers all
over the European Union
um can use their cell phone as if at
home so a lot of different legislations
form the internal markets safe are
actually good for the consumers and the
business here it's important that you
mention Roman for example because many
of the citizens don't know that this
legislation comes from the European
Union indeed so you mentioned the main
benefits we will discuss about it later
on as well but on the contrary what are
the most pressing challenges
um I would say of course at the moment
we have this overall challenge that is
the war in Ukraine High Energy prices
inflation that are having a lot of
impact on businesses and consumers in
the European Union we saw that
especially during the pandemic the last
big crisis before the war Supply chains
were interrupted and borders were closed
again because of
yeah the virus that doesn't really stop
at the border
um so the internal Market always
basically I think needs to react to
those crisis needs to evolve and at the
end I would say the single market and
its tools
are always the solution or can be the
solution to the different challenges we
face in the European Union but I would
say in general the state of the second
Market is quite good because in the last
years we really got rid of a lot of
barriers in the European Union and I
think the internal Market is really
almost complete if you would say so and
what would be the next steps or for
example how would you imagine
celebrating this in the 50 years of the
single Market
I think when you look at the different
challenges we are already on a good way
but we could still accelerate some of
our policy making when it comes to the
internal market for example
um one of the biggest challenges for me
is the climate crisis and we have put
forward some interest in legislation
that will help to fight the climate
crisis for example the common charger
where we will save resources in the
future because we don't need 50
different cables anymore or we will have
very soon the right to repair that will
make it easier to repair our products
and not just throw them away but we need
to accelerate our green transition also
when it comes to the internal market and
using it as a tool
second issue I would say what I would
like to see in 50 years single Market is
that
um with the digital Services Act and the
digital markets act we also started to
regulate the digital single market and
to regulate the big platforms and this
is so important when it comes to
defending democracy because we see that
so much hate speed and this information
is spread on social media so the DSA and
the dma are very important First Steps
but I think we also here need to really
look ahead and see what else is to be
done you know regarding these two
legislation the Digital Services act and
digital markets act how can you policy
makers really design a true digital
single markets
um going farther yeah I think there is
um still a lot of Digital Services that
are not harmonized and where they're
still fragmentation going on that makes
it a little bit more difficult to
consumers or even has basically safety
gaps for consumers so I think this is
one important point I think the second
issue is that we need to use
digitalization much more better for the
green transition but also make sure that
with digitalization we don't accelerate
climate change for example using green
energy in the data centers or and so on
and so on is a very important tool and
then thirdly
I think we need to really start very
fast now with the DSA and the dma
implementation we see with the Takeover
of Twitter by Elon Musk and all the mess
it created that starting to implement
the DSA very fast and then also see
where it might be potential gaps and
then continue to improve it in the
future is important and do we have a
date for the implementation of these
acts yeah I mean the commission is now
really basically looking into it and
evaluating the different platforms and
which category they fall
um so there is a transition a period of
a couple of months but then it must be
implemented okay where you mentioned
before the covid-19 crisis but what
about the brexit how it has influenced
the single Market
yeah for me um it is really still very
surprising that the United Kingdom that
was always the biggest defender of the
single market and also the biggest fan
of the single Market at the end decided
to not only leave the European Union but
also the single Market with all the
negative implications if you look at the
UK economy it's not going well you can
really see that businesses but also
citizens they fight with a red tape with
their Customs
it made just life and trade business
much much more difficult for for the
people over there and GDP growth is
going down trade is going down and so I
think with all of that which is a very
sad story the rest of the European Union
basically got more aware of the benefits
the single Market really brings because
I don't know about you but sometimes you
have something around you you take it
for granted and you don't really value
it but I think unfortunately with brexit
every one of us probably values now a
little bit more what we have
also the war in Ukraine has had a
significant impact on the business
community so how do you perceive this in
relation to the single Market yeah
um I think um also here the single
Market can be and is the solution to a
lot of problems we know for example that
most of the experts of smes for example
go to other EU countries go to the
single market so having short supply
chains exporting to the European is a
very very important
factor for for our businesses and this
is important when it comes to also
interrupted Global Supply chains to
really rely on the single Market also
for example when it comes to some raw
materials that we are kind of that we
were importing from Russia to make sure
that we have a kind of internal Market
solidarity and see where we end at the
end need resources where we can get them
from in the internal Market
um I think what we see at the moment
that some member states take a lot of
money in their hands in order to support
their companies with the energy crisis
is absolutely legitimate because of
course they don't want their companies
to go bankrupt but we saw see also now
an imbalance and kind of dangerous
imbalance in the internal market and we
have to I think find for find common
Solutions find European solutions to
that
um apparently one of the proposed cells
of one of these Solutions of the the
European environment is working on is
related to the so-called single Market
instrument emergency instrument
um why does the European Union need such
an instrument or do you think it needed
yeah we have seen in the past some
crises where Supply chains in the
European Union got interrupted we talked
about the covet pandemic already but
there was also whatever a volcano
eruption imagine any crisis that can
happen where naturally member states
react in closing borders and looking
more inwards and I think the single
Market emergency instrument is important
to take these Lessons Learned and see
how can we prevent this in the future
how can we keep our single Market
functioning and benefit more from each
other cooperate more with each other so
that is why I really welcomed the
commission proposal we start working on
on this legislative file very soon in in
the parliament
and are there other ways in that um are
possible to do the single Market more
resilience or what can the European
Parliament do to do this in the market
more resilient
uh for me but it's probably not really
surprising to you because I'm also a
green politician for me resilience has
to do a lot also with being resilient
against climate change so I think the
more and the faster we advance the green
transition
and the more we make our internal Market
agree internal Market
the better and the more resilient it is
for the supply chains the more resilient
our supply chains will be the more
resilient also our businesses are
um and I think for keeping the whole
internal Market result I think it is
important as I mentioned to have not a
division and not a Divergence but really
try to keep all the different EU member
states economies together and not
overspend each other basically and
indeed um the European economy is
undergoing a rapid transition and with
digital technology and climate change it
needs said to transport the normal trade
so if the European Parliament doing
enough or what is it doing to support
this transition and yeah that is yeah I
think to support transition I think you
have two options normally one is rules
or regulation and the other one is
subsidies funds money uh and I think we
are doing both on European level
if it is enough you can probably tell me
or the listeners can tell me but
um when it comes to funds for example
after the corona pandemic
I think to having this like common
European approach to rebuild our economy
was very very important and I think we
need something similar now like a more
solidaric
investment opportunity in the transition
European businesses we also need for the
energy crisis or to fight the basically
the the results of inflation and we also
need clear regulation what a lot of
businesses tell me all the time that
they want certainty they want to know
where we are going what they should
invest and so I think having a strong
but also clear
rules that basically Foster the green
transformation are very important and is
it is the parliament or the EU policy
makers already working in building this
legislation for the for climate change
and the green transition yes I mean I
would say the whole fit for 55 the green
deer legislation we are in my committee
especially working on circular economy
files to make sure that all products of
the future are really designed in a
circular way and not in a linear way and
can be thrown after two years which is
really bad for the environment and for
the climate and so these kind of
legislation are underway at the moment
but of course again as a green
politician I would say it could even go
faster and we could be more ambitious
but this is always a democratic process
of course of different interests going
back to the long-awaited common charger
which I guess it's an example of a
circular economy as well this will be a
reality in 2024.
um could you explain how this will help
consumers yeah the common charger is
probably one good example of what I just
tried to explain that you need clear
rules because for like 12 years we had
like a voluntary agreement so the
commission tried to do a voluntary
approach with the companies but at the
end it didn't really work and now after
12 years the parliament was fighting
very much for this we finally have a
solution and we will have a common EU
charger and it will help the environment
because we will save resources but it
will also help the consumers because you
don't have to worry about different
types of cables you bring and different
basically electronic devices you have it
will make all of our Lives much easier
so what about yeah how can the single
Market encourage productivity and
Innovation as well because we are
talking about legislation for businesses
um in order to to go for the I mean to
yeah to achieve the the transition but
what about the production and Innovation
will this be stiffer yeah I mean you
still because of it's such a big Market
I guess you have a lot of competition
and I think this automatically also
Spurs Innovation I think we also have
quite good research funds on European
level that of course also are directed
in in Innovation and I would say really
the majority in this house also has a
very strong wish and we really take care
of it that the legislation doesn't
hamper Innovation so it's it has to be
clear but of course it still needs to
let Innovation uh to to flourish
basically
um many people in Europe and many of our
followers in social media are worried
about social inequalities
we we received some complaints also
about the inflation in our social media
post so what would you say to them can
the ceiling can the single market help
to reduce this social inequalities
yeah
um
from its beginning I would say this the
single market and the European
integration had
a missing social angle so from the
beginning it was not very clear like
social issues were left to member states
and the European Union to care about
economic integration but I also think
this is wrong and this was a mistake in
the past years also this Parliament has
been fighting for a much much stronger
social dimension of the internal Market
with specific social rules like for
example pay transparency now or the
minimum wage and so on and so on so I
think there's at the moment a lot of
good and important social rules that had
been voted here and that they're still
under discussion
um for when it comes to the inflation I
think what I said before is really
important that we need to take care that
all over Europe the member states have
the capacity to help their consumers
help their businesses and not only the
Richer member states so we need this
yeah solidaric approach I would say
so we received some comments from our
audience and some of them say congrats
congrats on the 30 years of the single
market and also I would like to read the
one from Damian Perez who says
historical moment for the development of
Europe bestest best decision ever
however there is a another question from
Peter on LinkedIn and he says do you
believe that in the future more problems
will arise from a shared International
currency in combination with the Bahrain
National constitutions and policy with
an international currency yes from a
shared International currency in
combination with different National
policies
um probably this question refers to the
euro crisis that we had some years ago
where we really saw okay the common
currency the Euro that we are having is
putting some constraints on for example
evaluation capacities of member states
and if you're in a crisis like Greece it
was like really difficult to develop
your money because you're in the Euro I
think back then it was a really horrible
time and it also really showed the
weaknesses of of the system and I think
some of the policy changes we did since
then improved the situation
um but I would say that we are still not
finished for me a proper economic
European economic governance would be
basically the solution but we are not
there yet but with the discussion on the
future of the U I think this also had
come back again and whether what I'll
turn
does Europe have to compete against some
foreign companies which are normally
supported or regularly supported by
state funding yeah
um what we decided in in this house a
couple of months ago
is a so-called anti-subsidy instrument
so when basically countries like okay I
can't just name the country if countries
like China pay a lot of subsidies to the
state-owned companies and then basically
also compete here on the internet Market
we now have some tools in our hand
to basically not undermine our companies
but have like really a Fair competition
and fight this unfair competition that
is probably started by China but
potentially also by some other countries
um to sign up sum up thanks to the
single Market we live love study and
work all over Europe across borders so
how could citizens cross-border rights
could be improved or strengthened
further
very important because for me I have to
say the most important part of the
European Union and also of the single
Market is the citizens at the end
everything we do everything we try to
achieve it's for the sake of a citizen
so yeah citizens rights are really
really really important and there is big
and small measures one I find
small but also really really important
one of my green colleagues is working on
it it is a statute for basically
European associations that if citizens
from both sides of the Border they want
to found an association they can just do
it because at the moment this is quite
difficult so there's still very very
important small and bigger steps where
we can improve basically the rights of
of EU citizens perfect
thank you so much for your time today it
was a pleasure to have you here and
thank you and to all our followers for
tuning in once again have a good evening
and yeah have a good evening as well
thank you